PROLONGED HEAT WAVE, EUROPE IS
ALREADY BRACING FOR WHAT COULD
BE A LONG, COLD WINTER BECAUSE
OF RUSSIA'S WAR ON UKRAINE.
EU MEMBER STATES TODAY AGREED
TO VOLUNTARILY REDUCE NATURAL
GAS DEMAND BY 15% THIS WINTER
WHILE FACING POSSIBLE SUPPLY
DISRUPTIONS.
THAT ACTION COMES ONE DAY AFTER
RUSSIA ANNOUNCED IT IS CUTTING
THE FLOW OF GAS FROM THE NORD
STREAM 1 PIPELINE TO ONE FIFTH
CAPACITY IN WHAT THE EU ENERGY
MINISTER CALLS A POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED MOVE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT BAG
AGREEMENT OUT OF THE EU.
CLARE SEBASTIAN IS WITH ME.
THE EUROPEANS ARE SAYING THAT
THIS COMES OFF THE BACK OF THE
RESTRICTION IN GAS SUPPLIES BY
THE RUSSIANS, SUGGESTING THIS
IS RUSSIA WEAPONIZING GAS.
RUSSIANS HAVE A REASON, THEY
SAY, FOR CUTTING OR FURTHER
REDUCING THIS GAS SUPPLY.
EXPLAIN WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
>> YEAH, WE ALL KNEW FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE WAR IN UKRAINE
THAT YOU WERE NEVER GOING TO BE
ABLE TO REPLACE ALL THE RUSSIAN
GAS WITH OTHER GAS.
THERE WAS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
DEMAND REDUCTION.
WE HAVE A VERY URGENT
SITUATION.
UNTIL THE RECENT COST TO THE
SUPPLY COMING THROUGH NORD
STREAM, IT WAS THE BIGGEST
SINGLE ARTERY SUPPLYING RUSSIAN
GHASTLIER UP.
IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
IT WAS AT 40% CAPACITY.
RUSSIA SAYS THAT ANOTHER
TURBINE NEEDS REPAIR.
ONE IS ALREADY ON ITS WAY BACK
FROM CANADA.
RUSSIA SAYS IT IS NOT ARRIVED
YET.
ANOTHER ONE NEEDS REPAIR.
THEY SAY IT NEEDS A CUT OF --
THE EU SAYS THAT IS A PRETEXT.
THIS IS A POLITICAL ISSUE.
MEANWHILE, THAT HAS STEPPED OUT
THE URGENCY FOR THE EU TO AGREE
ON THIS NEW DEAL TO CUT ENERGY
AND GAS DEMAND BY 15% THIS
WINTER.
IT IS A VOLUNTARY MEASURE.
THE 15% --
IF THERE IS AN EMERGENCY AND IT
TRIGGERS A UNION ALERT, IT
BECOMES MANDATORY.
HERE IS WHERE WE GET THE
COMPROMISES.
IN ORDER TO GET THIS OVER THE
LINE, THEY HAVE TO AGREE TO
EXEMPTIONS.
THEY HAVE TO AGREE TO
EXEMPTIONS FOR COMPANIES LIKE
IRELAND AND MALTA, WHO ARE NOT
CONNECTED TO THE PIPELINE.
THE BALTICS ARE NOT CONNECTED
TO THE ELECTRICITY GRID.
THERE ARE A FEW OTHER
DEROGATION'S, THEY ARE CALLED,
WHERE PEOPLE CAN REDUCE THE
TARGET TO SOMETHING LOWER.
CRITICS SAY IT IS WATERED DOWN,
BUT IT GOT OVER THE LINE FIVE
DAYS.
>> IT GOT OVER THE LINE AND
FIVE DAYS.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE 12 OF 21
MEMBER STATES WHO DIDN'T LIKE
THE IDEA OF A EUROPE WIDE
MANDATE ON GAS RATIONING.
THAT IS EFFECTIVELY WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
LOOK, THE CLOCKS ARE ALREADY
APPEARING.
WE ARE HEARING FROM THE
HUNGARIAN GOVERNMENT.
THE CHIEF SPOKESPERSON QUOTED
THE FOREIGN MINISTER.
HE SAID, FOR HUNGARY, THIS
DECISION IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE.
ITS IMPLEMENTATION IS OUT OF
THE QUESTION.
HE CONTINUED THE PROPOSAL AND
COMPLETELY --
WE ARE SEEKING MORE CLARITY ON
THIS FROM THE HUNGARIAN
GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE CERTAINLY VERY OPPOSED
TO IT.
THEY HAVE BEEN OPPOSED TO THE
NUMBER OF THE MEASURES THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO GARNER AGREEMENT ON
AN EU WIDE LEVEL.
IT SHOWS HOW CONTROVERSIAL THIS
IS AND HOW POWERFUL RUSSIA'S
LEVERAGE STILL IS WHEN IT COMES
TO ITS ENERGY SUPPLIES.
>> IT WAS AN IMF REPORT TODAY
SIGNIFICANTLY DOWNGRADING
GLOBAL GROWTH THIS YEAR, WHICH
POINTED OUT THAT IN THE
EUROPEAN SPACE THERE COULD BE
EVEN FURTHER DOWNGRADES SHOULD
THINGS GET REALLY DIFFICULT
THIS WINTER.
THE RIPPLE EFFECT OF THIS
RUSSIAN WAR ON UKRAINE IS
REALLY BEING FELT IN THE HEART
OF EUROPE.
>> IT REALLY IS.
THE GERMAN ECONOMY, THE BIGGEST
IN EUROPE, IS THE MOST RELIANT
ON RUSSIAN GAS.
IT IS SO IMPACTFUL.
THE IMF HAS DOWNGRADED GLOBAL
GROWTH FROM 6.1% TO 3.2%.
THEY SAY THAT IF RUSSIA CUT THE
GAS TO EUROPE COMPLETELY, IT
WILL GO TO 2.6%.
YOU CAN SEE THE IMPACT.
THERE IS THAT UNCERTAINTY.
THIS IS STILL HANGING OVER
EUROPE.
RUSSIA HAS USED THE TACTIC OF
INCREMENTALLY REDUCING THE
SUPPLIERS TO SORT OF HOLD OVER
EUROPE THIS LEVERAGE.
THAT IS WHY WE SEE THE URGENCY
TODAY WITH THE DEMAND CUTS.
>> I SPOKE TO THE SPOKESMAN FOR
THE TURKISH PRESIDENT THE OTHER
DAY.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT WHETHER
HE BELIEVED RUSSIA COULD BE
TRUSTED WITH THIS GRAIN DEAL,
THE EXPORT OF GRAIN.
IN ORDER TO TRY TO PREVENT THIS
CATASTROPHIC FOOD CRISIS, HE
MADE A POINT WHICH I THINK IS
IMPORTANT.
I THINK WE HAVE THIS NOW.
HE MADE A POINT WHICH WAS
EFFECTIVELY --
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE IT.
ANYWAY, HIS POINT WAS THAT
EUROPE SHOULD NOT REALLY BE
SURPRISED BY RUSSIA'S EFFORTS
AT THIS POINT TO WEAPONIZE GAS.
AFTER ALL, THE SESSIONS IN THE
RUSSIAN OIL INDUSTRY HAVE QUITE
FRANKLY HAD A MASSIVE IMPACT,
HAVEN'T THEY?
>> EVEN BEFORE THAT, THIS HAS
BEEN PART OF RUSSIA'S PLAYBOOK
FOR A LONG TIME.
YOU AND I REMEMBER THE GAS CUTS
TO UKRAINE OVER A NUMBER OF
YEARS ABOUT A DECADE AGO.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THEY
HAVE WEAPONIZED BEFORE.
OIL --
THIS IS COMING MORE FROM THE
EUROPEAN SIDE.
THE EU HAS NOW ANNOUNCED THIS
GRADUAL EMBARGO.
YOU DON'T REALLY SEE RUSSIA
WEAPONIZING ITS OIL SUPPLY IS
QUITE AS MUCH AS YOU DO WITH
ITS GAS SUPPLIES.
OIL IS A MUCH BIGGER PART OF
THE FEDERAL BUDGET.
GAS IS SMALLER.
THEY ARE ABLE TO USE THAT.
PLUS, THE PRICES ARE NOW SO
HIGH THEY ARE MAKING MORE MONEY
THAN BEFORE EVEN THOUGH THE
EXPERTS ARE DOWN.
>> KEEP AN EYE ON THE EURO.
AROUND ABOUT PARITY.
THAT CURRENCY IS FRAGILE IN THE
FACE OF WHAT COULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT DOWNTURN IN
ECONOMIC GROWTH GOING FORWARD
FOR EUROPE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH INDEED.
>> I WANT TO TALK MORE ABOUT
EUROPE'S ENERGY CONUNDRUM.
WE ARE WORKING ON TRANSITIONING
TO NEW FORMS OF ENERGY WHERE
THE GLOBAL ENERGY CONSULTANCY
AFTER THE.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE CAN TALK
ABOUT.
BEFORE WE DO THAT, THIS WAS A
COMPROMISE DEAL.
IT REFLECTS THE FACT THAT
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES ARE IN VERY
DIFFERENT POSITIONS WHEN IT
COMES TO RELIANCE ON GAS FROM
RUSSIA AND RELIANCE ON GAS FOR
THEIR ELECTRICITY AS A WHOLE.
ONE SIZE FITS ALL MANDATE FROM
THE EU.
IT IS JUST NOT GOING TO WORK,
IS IT?
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
YOU CAN BASICALLY SEE BETWEEN
THE MEDITERRANEAN COUNTRIES
THERE ARE POLITICAL ASPECTS --
COUNTRIES LIKE GREECE, LOOKING
AT --
[INAUDIBLE]
FEEL A LITTLE BIT OF
SCHADENFREUDE.
TECHNICAL ASPECTS AS WELL.
SPAIN, FRANCE, PORTUGAL ARE NOT
CONNECTED TO THE EUROPEAN GAS
NETWORK.
THEY CAN'T REALLY DO MUCH FOR
GERMANY IN THAT CONTEXT.
IT'S QUITE THE CONTRARY,
ACTUALLY.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> THIS WAS A SIGNIFICANT
ANNOUNCEMENT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR GAS REDUCTION
INCOME OF THE WINTER IN EUROPE.
UNLESS INDIVIDUAL CONSUMERS,
SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZED
ENTERPRISES AND INDUSTRY, CAN
SLASH DEMAND AT THIS POINT.
AS YOU HAVE DONE ENOUGH, DO YOU
THINK, OR COULD WE SEE FURTHER
CUTS?
>> YOU CAN ALWAYS SEE FURTHER,
OF COURSE.
HOW MUCH IS ENOUGH?
YOU HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
RUSSIA IS NOT GOING TO CUT GAS
SUPPLIES TO THE EU.
THAT IS NOT IN THEIR INTEREST
ANYWAY.
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO --
IT WILL PROBABLY RAISE THE
SUPPLIES AS WELL.
THIS HAS TWO ADVANTAGES FROM
THE RUSSIAN PERSPECTIVE.
THANK YOU THE EUROPEAN
RESILIENCE RELATIVELY LOW.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, OF COURSE,
THEY ARE JACKING UP GAS PRICES,
BASICALLY.
THEY ARE APPROACHING 200 --
THAT IS BASICALLY WELCOME CASH
FOR RUSSIA.
OVERALL, THE GAS SUPPLY WILL
NOT BE DIMINISHED AND
DISAPPEAR.
OF COURSE, THE FEAR FROM THE
CUT IS ACTIVELY MORE EFFECTIVE
THAN THE CUT ITSELF.
>> HOW DO YOU RATE EUROPEAN
LEADERSHIP AT THIS POINT WHEN
IT COMES TO SUCH A CRITICAL
ISSUE?
THERE IS GAS DEMAND AND SUPPLY.
IT'S NOT JUST THE WINTER, OF
COURSE.
WE ARE HAVING A HEAT WAVE THIS
SUMMER.
THE AIR CONDITIONING UNITS ARE
OFTENTIMES WORKING OFF OF GAS
POWERED ELECTRICITY AS WELL.
HOW DO YOU RATE IT?
HAS EUROPE THOUGHT THIS THROUGH
ENOUGH, DO YOU BELIEVE?
>> NO, NOT REALLY.
THESE ARE GOING TO THE
POLITICAL ANALYSIS.
OVERALL, IT IS A MESS, REALLY,
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
I MEAN, IT IS --
>> A MESS THAT HAS A RIPPLE
EFFECT ON THE EUROPEAN
ECONOMIES.
WE HAVE SEEN ON IMF DOWNGRADED.
>> YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER THAT WE
ARE NOW IN A VERY TIGHT LNG
MARKET FOR STARTING FROM THE
END OF LAST YEAR TOWARD
ACCORDING TO OUR ANALYSIS
TOWARDS 2026, EVEN.
THAT ISSUE EUROPE IS FACING
RIGHT NOW IS PROBABLY NOT THE
END OF THE WORLD.
WE WILL SEE THE SAME THEATER IN
WINTER 2024, IN WINTER 2025.
IT WILL REPEAT ITSELF.
OF COURSE, LIKE WE SAID WITH
THE HIGH GAS PRICES, COUNTRIES
LIKE JAPAN AND SOUTH KOREA HAVE
TO PAY A PREMIUM OTHER
COUNTRIES SUCH AS PAKISTAN,
BANGLADESH ARE BASICALLY PRICED
OUT OF THE MARKET.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT THIS SORT OF
SENSE OF SCHADENFREUDE BY THE
LIGHTS OF THE GREEKS AND --
THE COUNTRY THAT IS IN THE REAL
CROSSHAIRS AT THIS POINT WHEN
IT COMES TO INDUSTRY IS THE
INDUSTRIAL HEARTLAND OF EUROPE.
IT IS GERMANY.
DO YOU SEE THE AMBITION FOR
REDUCING RELIANCE ON RUSSIAN
ENERGY ACCELERATING?
DO YOU SEE THE AMBITION QUICK
ENOUGH?
I KNOW THAT THIS HAS COME OUT
EVERYBODY VERY QUICKLY.
IT IS YOUR BUSINESS TO TALK
ABOUT CLEAN ENERGY, DIVERSIFIED
FLOWS GOING FORWARD.
WHAT ARE WE SEEING BEHIND THE
SCENES?
BEHIND THE SCENES, THERE IS A
GOOD LIKELIHOOD THAT THE GERMAN
INDUSTRY PRESSURES THE GERMAN
GOVERNMENT, CUTTING A DEAL
BEHIND THE SCENES WITH PUTIN,
TELLING HIM BASICALLY, WE ARE
GOING TO SUBSCRIBE TO TEN YEARS
OF GAS SUPPLIES AND SUPPLY US
WITH THAT AMOUNT OF GAS.
THERE IS NO OPTION FOR GERMANY
IN PARTICULAR.
>> THIS IS THE EUROPEAN
STEPPING DOWN?
EFFECTIVELY?
THAT WOULD SUGGEST A FRACTURING
IN THIS EUROPEAN UNITY.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THAT IS NOW
HAPPENING?
>> ABSOLUTELY, FROM PUTIN'S
PERSPECTIVE, NOT CUTTING GAS ON
HUNDRED PERCENT IS CREATING
FRACTURING.
IF HE WILL CUT THE GAS ON THIS
PERSON, THE WHOLE EUROPE SHOULD
COME TOGETHER AND OPERATE.
THE SUPPLIES IN THAT COUNTRY,
THIS COUNTRY, HE CREATES THIS
FRACTURE.
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS VERY CYNICAL,
GIVEN THE CURRENT TRAGEDY, BUT
HE PLAYS THE GAME REALLY WELL,